hi guys it's over at again and today I'm
actually gonna start off with something
different I figured I didn't even do any
textures on the terrain yet and this is
something that sometimes I see people
not to pay any attention attention to
this and it's something very quick very
easy and it can really make your coaster
look a lot better just adding some
simple sand textures here and there may
be some mud or rocky textures depending
on the theme I always like to do it
around certain things so for example
I've got a war over here I always like
to add a slight different texture around
that because logically this grass
wouldn't go on like that if there are
rocks and all that kind of stuff over
there and next to a lake like I have in
this case I always like to add some sand
or rocky textures so stuff like that so
I'm actually gonna start off by making
it a two square which means that you can
kind of cover a pretty small area too
large enough to not take years to
basically do all of this but it's also
small enough to do not mess it up
because if you take a larger area that
might work but sometimes you're gonna
miss it and then you have to erase it
again or you can't exactly it and get
the shape you want and if you do a two
square thing you can do a one square
thingy and you can also do a two square
white well area on which you change the
textures so that's what I always use
though if you have a bigger lake say for
example the lake is pretty much this big
then I would recommend using a 4 or a 5
texture thing now what I also like to do
with this is just bring it down to one
and just sprinkle some other textures on
there just like this on the sides just
so you have some different stuff as well
the faster you do it the better it turns
out because as you can see I did it kind
of slow over here so I'm just gonna go
over there with this thing again and I
will have to change this because this
might happen actually this happens
pretty often and it's quite unfortunate
because if you have buildings so you
want to smooth this out because just by
smoothing this out you can solve that
but I so I'll show that in a minute
just by smoothing that out you can fix
it but if you've got buildings for
example it might really screw that all
stuff over so yeah I would already
always recommend to do terraforming
first and then the buildings because the
way terraforming works in this game is
sometimes very annoying but oh well I've
got some nice little sand textures
underneath that and I'm gonna just add
some simple mud underneath the coaster
also mixing in with some other types and
textures only problem is I've got these
things over here and as soon as there's
a cliff on the side the textures won't
well transition smoothly like they
normally do as you can see you can kind
of see in the middle there you can see
that little thing right goes from the
mud into the grass and that's very
unfortunate so if you have a cliff thing
like this you're gonna have to use the
same texture around the entire thing
just to make sure that it's not going to
do that weird clipping thing and I'm
just going to do it like that you know
that works and I'm I wanted to actually
mix in a couple of other textures but
since I've got all these clippings
that's pretty much impossible since I
would not recommend having those weird
not smooth transitions because they can
look very terrible
okay now this looks pretty decent but I
will add some more sand textures so I'm
just gonna quickly go over this with
this texture that's not too bad except I
do see this over there it kind of works
though I kind of want to like to text
you I always like to mix this one and
that one or this one and that one mixing
textures is always a great idea but in
this case it doesn't work because you've
got those cliff things going on but it
would normally look something like this
yeah it's pretty much in between that
kind of works just slightly brushing it
and if it doesn't look good you can
brush it using the other texture again
like I just did I can see some part
where it's not very smooth also in there
so that definitely needs some fixing at
some point but not right now um I'm
gonna focus on their regular textures
and stuff first so just going to do that
I'm gonna add some sand in here because
I can
that won't work I can actually though
add some textures in here
even this needs smoothing so yeah that's
this can sometimes be very annoying but
all you really have to do is just take
the smoothing tool and hope that it's
not going to screw up any of the
buildings or supports in this case
because those footers and connectors are
very good at doing that okay I'm just
gonna see and hopefully it's not going
to screw it up
also if you smooth like this sometimes
people just smooth like this okay you
can see that that while they're not
smooth parts over here but if you do
this for some reason the game makes that
makes those edges shift to like probably
these tiles I don't know why it does
that but I find that making a pretty big
area and just smoothing along the entire
thing wow I just used the wrong tool
that was nice that works yeah so now
it's all smooth I'm gonna do the same
thing over here okay great and I think
that was it's anything I've still got is
this thing okay that's going to be hard
since you can't make the smooth tool too
wide and one long so I'm just gonna try
this using this tool
now wait this too will make it this one
snaps to grid okay that kind of works
let's see like that yeah there we go
nice so everything should be smooth
right now I'm gonna add some textures in
here simply because I don't really like
the look of that grass and there it
doesn't really make too much sense so
I'm just gonna add a conforming path
path set and I like to use
Ralphie's paths since it's conforming
and it has a lot of interesting textures
so we trying to find it right now there
we go and I like this pattern but I feel
like either the pebble pattern or this
second one might be the best idea I
don't know that you've got a dark one
and
light one and then you've also got this
plaster who might actually use this okay
let me just try this just some simple
text in those things yeah that works and
I might always add edges at the
beginning and the side of that okay
I usually also try to use track beds for
these but in this case since it's more
into into the ground that doesn't work
but I'll show that trick bet trick at
some point okay
oh wow make sure you actually place them
on the full tile because otherwise
they'll do this and it they'll sometimes
be hard to remove and be clipping and
stuff like that so make sure that you
place them on the full tile placement
and not in the middle of half a tile
okay the track beds yeah I'm just gonna
show off the track beds it's just a
little trick that sometimes people use
there is a track bed set which is
supposed to be used for trains but
actually many people use that sets for
just some simple track beds underneath
the coaster track it looks pretty
interesting but it also works for stuff
like this if your land is flat so in
this case I've gone those cliff faces at
the sides so I can't really use these
flat track beds but if you caught a flat
piece of land you can definitely use
these things and then the trick is just
to place them underneath the track and
make the ground underneath its wrecked
look a little bit a little bit less
boring
that's basically it it's more common
when the track is very close to the
ground to prevent the track from hitting
grass and adding a track bed kind of
makes it seem more realistic since yeah
I Kosar a hitting grass makes no sense
but well a man-made track bed does make
sense okay now I'm just gonna see if I
can bring this down to the ground
because that's gonna be quite hard
okay let's see diagonal slope okay that
works yeah that's actually pretty nice
it looks pretty cool just a little trick
okay now I'm just gonna get that gentle
slope down and do the same thing over
here I'm gonna replace those fritters
because obviously those fritters kind of
you need to photos if you've got a track
pant like this too so I'm gonna do that
right away before I forget about that
let's see and once again when it comes
to footers you can kind of see the
placements this is a corner placement
it's in the middle of the tile make this
gray and this same color as the supports
okay that works
and now to take the diagonal one there
we go yeah it's kind of in the middle of
the track bed but this is probably
better than raising it a lot because
these photos are usually not raised a
lot they're best for flat areas but
since this coaster doesn't have too much
well levitation going on I mean
elevation that's why I figured I might
as well use these photos now this one
seems to be raised for some reason but
that's better yeah okay that's all good
and then there's one last thing
adding rocky textures along these rocks
because may boat basically if you've got
rocks especially on mountains and stuff
like that yeah and the rocks always kind
of erode and you get these little
pebbles along the rocks so I'm just
gonna take some random rock textures and
kind of brush that along these things
you can also use sand for this it's a
little bit more uncommon but it also
works okay it's more over here
I might actually blend in a bit of sand
and now this texture is really dark but
it really gives that rocky texture so I
like to use that here and there
don't use that all over the place
because it'll make everything pretty
much pitch black but I like it I like to
just brush it around like everywhere and
give it a bit more of that rocky Tex
you feel might also blend in some sand
no no I think of it let's see yeah that
works as well makes it a bit more yellow
in this gray okay I think those are some
pretty nice textures I would usually the
reason why I didn't put the grid on and
the beginning of the episode is because
you can see though the way that textures
look a lot better when you turn the grid
off like with the grid on you can kind
of see them but you can't really get the
general idea of the way it looks and
when you turn it off it's a lot more
realistic you don't have that grid to
well look at instead of the actual
textures so that's a lot better so when
you're terraforming I would always
recommend turning the grid off but in
any other case building supports
building buildings even doing a layouts
I would turn the grid on especially with
the layout actually since you can kind
of see where the coast is going to go if
you want to connect it to the station
for example and by the way to smooth
this out always use this tool you can
always also use this tool this the
average ur also kind of got rids of the
kind of gets rid of the edges but you
can see that it also changes the terrain
a little and this is one tool that will
always screw up your buildings if you've
got terraforming going on so I would
always recommend just using the normal
smoothing tool speaking of smoothing
what the hell happened over there that's
definitely a job for this tool well I'm
gonna fix that later on doesn't really
matter at this point anyways thank you
for watching this episode of the
tutorial next time I'm gonna do the path
work again so till then